Traductor: Mónica Martín Palmas
Revisor: María Julia Galles
En 2004,
una nueva empresa llamada Vemma Nutrition
empezó a ofrecer una oportunidad única
de obtener ingresos de jornada completa
trabajando a jornada parcial.
La oferta de Vemma era para todo el mundo,
sin importar la experiencia previa
o la formación académica.
Solo había dos pasos antes
de empezar a ganar dinero:
comprar un kit de USD 500-600
de sus productos de nutrición líquida
y reclutar a dos personas
para que hicieran lo mismo.
La empresa Vemma Nutrition
creció rápidamente,
convirtiéndose en una operación mundial
que en su punto álgido conseguía
30 0000 nuevos miembros al mes.
Solo había un problema...
mientras que la empresa generaba USD 200
millones de ingresos anuales en 2013,
la inmensa mayoría de participantes
ganaba menos de lo invertido.
Vemma fue finalmente acusada
de ser un esquema piramidal:
un tipo común de fraude
donde los miembros ganan dinero
reclutando a personas para que inviertan.
Normalmente, el fundador solicita
a un primer grupo de gente
que compren y promuevan el sistema.
Entonces se les anima a reclutar a otros
y se les promete una parte
del dinero que invierten los otros
mientras que el fundador
también se lleva su parte.
El patrón se repite para cada
grupo de nuevos participantes,
con el dinero de los recién llegados
canalizado hacia los que los reclutaron.
Esto es diferente al esquema Ponzi,
donde los fundadores reclutan
nuevos miembros
y usan en secreto sus cuotas
para pagar a los miembros existentes,
que creen que sus pagos proceden
de inversiones legítimas.
Cuando el esquema piramidal crece,
cada vez es más difícil que
los nuevos miembros ganen dinero.
Eso ocurre porque el número
de participantes aumenta exponencialmente.
Por ejemplo, en una estructura en la que
cada persona debe reclutar a seis más,
el fundador recluta seis
personas para empezar
y cada una de ellas recluta seis más.
En la segunda ronda de
reclutamiento hay 36 personas,
que a su vez reclutan
seis personas cada una...
un total de 216 nuevos reclutas.
En la duodécima ronda de reclutamiento
los 2100 millones de
nuevos miembros deberían reclutar
más de 13 mil millones de personas
para poder ganar dinero,
más que toda la población mundial.
En este supuesto,
los reclutados más recientes,
que son más del 80 % de los participantes,
pierden todo el dinero que pagaron.
Y en la vida real,
muchos de los primeros
participantes también lo pierden.
Los esquemas piramidales
son ilegales en la mayoría de países,
pero es difícil detectarlos.
Se presentan como muchas cosas distintas,
incluyendo grupos de regalos,
clubes de inversión y empresas
de mercadotecnia multinivel.
La diferencia entre
los esquemas piramidales
y la mercadotecnia multinivel legítima
es especialmente confusa.
El teoría, la diferencia es
que los miembros de las empresas
de mercadotecnia multinivel
obtienen compensación mayormente por
vender un determinado producto o servicio
a compradores minoristas,
mientras que los esquemas piramidales
compensan por reclutar nuevos miembros.
Sin embargo, en la práctica
muchas empresas de
mercadotecnia multinivel imposibilitan
que los miembros obtengan
ganancias solo con las ventas.
Y muchos esquemas piramidales
como Vemma Nutrition
se disfrazan de empresas
de mercadotecnia multinivel legales,
utilizando un producto o servicio para
ocultar la estructura de pago por recluta.
Muchos esquemas piramidales
también capitalizan sobre
la confianza existente en iglesias,
comunidades de inmigrantes,
u otros grupos estrechamente unidos.
Se anima a los primeros miembros
a comunicar una experiencia positiva
incluso antes de empezar
a obtener beneficios.
Otros miembros de la comunidad
siguen su ejemplo
y el esquema crece sin control
antes de que sea evidente que muchos
de los miembros no obtienen ganancias.
Con frecuencia las víctimas
se avergüenzan en silencio.
Los esquemas piramidales atraen a la gente
con oportunidades y empoderamiento.
Así, cuando los miembros no
consiguen ningún beneficio,
se culpan a ellos mismos
antes que al esquema,
pensando que no han sido tenaces
para conseguir los beneficios prometidos.
Algunas víctimas lo siguen intentando
invirtiendo en múltiples esquemas
y perdiendo dinero cada vez.
A pesar de todos estos factores,
hay maneras de detectar
un esquema piramidal.
La presión temporal es
una señal de alarma:
cuidado con directivas como "actúe ya
o pierda la oportunidad de su vida".
Las promesas de grandes ingresos
que le cambiarán la vida
también son sospechosas.
Por último, una empresa legal
de mercadotecnia multinivel
no debería pedir a sus miembros que paguen
para vender un producto o servicio.
Los esquemas piramidales pueden ser
increíblemente dañinos para las personas,
las comunidades e incluso países enteros.
Pero puedes combatir el fuego con fuego
enviando este vídeo a
tres personas que conozcas
y animarles a que hagan lo mismo.